die geschichte kann fritz honka den
frauen 1970 er jahren im goldenen
handschuh in hamburg
ja die normale menschen ich habe mich
eigentlich den ganzen film durch der
schwer zu ertragen ist gefragt warum er
das gemacht hat warum ich gucke ist klar
warum fatih akin diesem film nachts da
hat sich bisher für mich gar nicht
erschlossen
eine leibliche tochter rosi zuzuführen
dass es sie vom naschen darf
im frauenhaus der darin zum ausdruck
kommt finde ich schmerzen automatisch
auch kontext los
[Musik]
der film soll sich in diesem rhythmus
des täters ist sehr nah dran an dem
täter
[Musik]
es ist auch ein herr offer muss man
sagen also das heißt wir sehen zwar
nicht wie im kopf abgesägt wird aber wir
hören das hört sich nicht schön an sie
würden sie nicht viel getrunken
ich habe zwischendurch hatte ich das
gefühl es ist vielleicht ein firma
alkoholismus der in dieser form als
wirklich also drogensucht nicht so
häufig im kino zu sehen ist
was ist eigentlich die geschichte die er
uns erzählen will denn die geschichte
von frank ackermann auf wikipedia
nachlesen also den ganzen unbedingt
interessiert wann er welches auch
ermordet hat noch genug zu trinken immer
vor wurde an der haltestelle noch nicht
los
auf jeden fall beides deutsche kino
bisher erstaunlich körperlich
erstaunlich intensiv da keine filme in
denen man einfach in die man einfach
reingeht und völlig unbeteiligt wieder
rauskommen
[Musik]